this is from uh bloomberg
it says a group of amazon.com and uh
incorporated employees plan to march in
seattle's pride parade on sunday so this
was an article that went out
before the pride parade which happened
yesterday
but this gives a little bit of context
to something that happened at this pride
parade so it says the amazon players
plan to march in seattle's pride parade
on sunday to protest the online
retailers sale of books that they
consider anti-transgender an action that
threatens to erode the company's image
as an inclusive employer in recent
months several hundred staffers have
been pushing the e-commerce giant to ban
books like irreversible damage the
transgender craze seducing our daughters
which is by abigail schreier
and as i've said one of the most
important books of this century if
you've never read that book you should
read it
they say that such titles dehumanize
trans people and dismiss their
identities as mental disorders which
runs counter to the recommendations of
almost every major medical group
employees say the books could confuse
vulnerable teens and their parents who
turn to amazon seeking information
and another target is johnny the walrus
a children's book by conservative
commentator matt walsh about a boy who
thinks he's a marine mammal the boy's
mother caving the pressure from the
internet people quote unquote feeds him
worms and takes him to a saw wielding
doctor who suggests turning his hands
and feet into fins that is a you know
pretty correct summation of the plot of
that book a spokesperson for the titles
publisher of the daily wire owned dw
books applauded amazon for dismissing
demands by its woke employees adding
that quote with nearly 100 000 copies
sold on amazon alone it's clear that
there is a huge demand for johnny the
walrus by amazon customers and we are
thrilled with the book's massive success
um
so we didn't get the as expected we
didn't get the apology statement from
daily wire i'm pretty shocked by that so
then the the uh
pride parade happens and the amazon
employees show up and i was really
hoping and rooting that they'd have some
signs with maybe images of johnny the
walrus i was hoping for like a sign
with a with a trans walrus you know
circled and crossed out or something now
we didn't get that but um here is what
we did get instead at the pride parade
go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right there's holding signs and say
no hate at amazon
[Music]
which i'm i'm fine with that message by
the way i agree
which is why there's nothing remotely
hateful
about johnny the walrus or about my
other best-selling book which is what is
a woman in book form which you can buy
at amazon and as it just so happens we
found out this weekend 360 platform
provides recruiters and sources and
companies i'm just listening okay he's
not saying anything important all right
we can turn that off so that's it that's
all they just marched with that banner
huge disappointment there but that was
the disappointment
um the good part is that we found out
over the weekend that what is a woman my
book was a woman uh was officially you
know made it officially onto the amazon
bestseller list for the week it made it
on the publisher weekly publishers
weekly bestseller list wall street
journal and pretty much every bestseller
list except for the new york times
because new york times has decided that
basically no daily wire book is allowed
to make it on their list anymore that
started with michael knowles in his book
speechless so really i blame him and
ever since then
no other daily wire book is allowed to
be on the new york times bestseller
johnny the walrus we sold like
what i don't even know what it was 50 60
000 copies in a week or something crazy
like that and we still didn't make it on
the new york times bestsellers but we
were on every other bestseller list for
what is a woman
including this is pretty funny the
seattle times this is the seattle pride
march and the seattle times bestseller
list we made that one also so you can go
to amazon.com right now and uh pick up
that book now
you know it's funny too that they lump
you know they lump me in with abigail
schreier and they lump in my books with
abigail schreier's books
but um
you know
my
approach
i will admit
can sometimes be um a little
provocative you know
and uh and i'll i'll admit that about
myself
even on johnny the walrus we never even
mention anything about trans people i
mean it's simply a story
of uh of a boy identifying as a walrus
that's all a lovely fanciful tale but in
general i'll admit that i take that
approach abigail schreier does not
and um her book
irreversible damage all all it simply
does is document
this
craze as it says in the subtitle
overtaking you know adolescent girls it
takes this phenomenon
which is that over the course of just a
few years transgender identification
skyrocketed to astronomical levels among
adolescent girls in particular and so
abigail schreier is noticing that in the
book and then trying to figure out why
that is happening
and in fact schreier i don't want to
misrepresent her view here but
she
i don't think and certainly not in the
book but even just herself individually
she doesn't take any
issue necessarily with the fundamental
premise of transgenderism like i do i do
take an issue with the fundamental
premise she does not at least not
publicly and i don't know how she feels
personally one way or another but and
the book doesn't
like the book actually doesn't say that
it's necessarily impossible
for a man to be a woman
the book just doesn't give an opinion on
that one way or another
all it does is talk about this
phenomenon as it affects
children
especially girls
and that's hate speech also
because when it comes to the uh the
trans mafia their message is clear
you're not allowed to talk about this
all of the you know
you can't even notice these problems
you cannot mention them to notice them
or mention them is hate speech
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts
you